Hey Charles.
>> Hey Michael, how's it going?
>> Not too bad.
I'm very excited because today we
get to talk about TD with Control.
>> Okay,
is that what that yellow thing is?
>> That's intended to
be a lightning bolt.
I don't know, somehow it just
convergence, TD with Control,
it sounded like a superhero movie to me.
>> Okay.
That makes perfect sense.
Why are you excited about this?
>> Well so, what we are going to talk
about is how to not just learn values
learning update rules like TD, but
to actually learn the values of
different actions we might take as a way
of figuring out the right way to behave.
>> Okay.
I like that.
>> Yeah.
And
we'll even get really close to
proving that these methods converge.
That is to say that,
given enough data over enough time,
they actually do the right thing.
>> Okay.
By the way, did you know
that Convergence is the name
of the 2015 company-wide
event in DC Comics?
>> Whoa!
Okay, so it is a superhero thing.
>> Yeah, well done.
>> Does that mean we get paid for
using their stuff, or
does that mean that we have to pay for
using their stuff?
>> I think it means that
we have to pay them so-
>> Oh, whoops.
>> Time to raise tuition.
>> Can I do that?
>> There you go,
now everything's taken care of.
>> Tada!